ce n'est pas dans mon habitude de faire
des discours mais je crois que le moment
est important
c'est que c'est pas facile d'avoir
atterri dans mon service après avoir été
validée et maille fine
et vous l'avez cherché il n'y a que des
ratés comme vous qui finissent à l'étape
et pour être honnête
travailler avec vous a été le pire
moment de ma misérable carrière
au boulot
sur c'est quoi la banque les débris de
ce qui fut un moment
et que c'était pareil qu'en prison et ça
se faisait pas demandé et ont même
pourquoi est-ce-que pas aussi envie de
servir à quelque chose ça serait
impossible de s'emmerder davantage
j'imagine que vous savez combien
d'agents ont réussi à réintégrer les
bureaux de région ce parc après les
tables c'est pire de devoir vous êtes
plié de quoi que ce soit que d'apprendre
à se raser à canards aucun
et mater sa prise d'otage merde c'est
chez nos têtes qu'on va pouvoir être
enfin à petit qu'est-ce que ça peut bien
vous [ __ ] pas par ce qui se passe
c'est du boulot pour de vrais agents
[Musique]
et
oui je sais on fait la sale besogne
jacques une piste et elle est peut-être
pour rien
tu va m'aider au non sûrement pas et tu
le veuilles ou non les tables est
désormais appliquée je joue à quoi je
peux savoir
je voulais pas le tuer évidemment si
vous l'avez vous lu ce pauvre type
seraient encore en vie
les gens risquent de mourir à cause de
toi c'est une opération photo mh
je dirige l'ensemble personnel le tien y
compris
elle efface les traces de son passage
mais c'est ce qu'on fait pour effacer
les traces qui finit par de trade
à vous le dis tiens non pour moi c'est
sérieux qu'une bande de tocards
mais c'est m car
[Musique]